[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN: Hello,
game developers.
And welcome to yet another
episode of "Game On!"
I'm your host, Todd Kerpelman.
And I'm here today
with Wolff Dobson, who
is not going to be
talking about physics,
but is going to be talking about
something just as exciting.
And that's the
turn-based multiplayer
features that we just
released a few days ago.
Wolff, why don't you
tell us about this stuff?
WOLFF DOBSON: I'd love to.
TODD KERPELMAN: Awesome
WOLFF DOBSON: So,
first question is,
what is Turn-Based Multiplayer?
Turn-Based Multiplayer
means a single shared state
passed between multiple players.
Only one player has
permission to edit the shared
state at a time.
Once you've edited it
as much as you want,
you pass it on to somebody else.
We support 2 to 8 players,
including Automatch.
And you can actually mix
and match your Automatch.
You can have some
invited players,
some Automatch players.
You can see all the
documentation and stuff
at this URL that our
producer has added here.
TODD KERPELMAN:
Oh, look at that.
Magic of post-processing.
WOLFF DOBSON: So
who can use this?
This is all part of
Google Play services.
So anything you want,
going back to Gingerbread,
it should be on your
phone right now,
or a Play Store
update very near you.
We're also publishing REST
bindings for web or desktop
apps.
But be warned, we don't really
have a notification system.
The notifications only
appear on Android.
And now let's do a little demo.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
WOLFF DOBSON: So this is a
game that I wrote called "8 Bit
Artist," and it uses the
Turn-Based Multiplayer.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right, well
I'm going to start a game here.
So this is basically a
guess what I'm drawing game.
But you've added
a fun twist to it,
which is the grid is
basically 10 by 10.
So all of our art
is equally crappy.
And as a crappy
artist, I appreciate
being put in the
same level playing
field as everybody else.
So I'm going to start a
match with this account.
And it looks like I
have some opponents
that I can choose from.
These are basically
populated from my G+ circles.
WOLFF DOBSON: And this is using
the built-in invitation UI
that we provide.
TODD KERPELMAN: Awesome.
Should I invite Vic Gangotra?
WOLFF DOBSON: No.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'll
just invite you.
WOLFF DOBSON: That's cool.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
WOLFF DOBSON: And then on
my screen-- there you go.
Now you have to
draw, so it's going
to give you a word to draw here.
TODD KERPELMAN: Reading.
That's actually a tough one.
I'm going to try
and draw a book.
And that looks like a heart.
You know what, because
this is a demo,
I'm not going to spend a lot
of time making this look good.
I'm just going to assume--
WOLFF DOBSON: It's
a heart bleeding.
TODD KERPELMAN:
This is very clearly
an awesome picture of a
book with words on it.
I think I'm--
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm just going to
press Done for you right there.
There we go.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
so this gets sent and--
WOLFF DOBSON: On
my screen, you see
that I got a little
pop-up that tells me
that the game was updated.
So now I can check
my available games.
And, sure enough, there's an
invitation from Todd Kerpelman.
So I'll accept his invitation.
And then it's my turn to guess
his amazing, amazing drawing.
Let me see here.
TODD KERPELMAN: So basically,
the state that got passed--
WOLFF DOBSON: It's lungs.
It's lungs.
It's definitely lungs.
TODD KERPELMAN: It kind
of looks like lungs.
WOLFF DOBSON: I have a
couple of choices here.
I have Reading, Victim, Spring,
Drink, Super Whale, Heart
and Lungs.
Now I have to--
TODD KERPELMAN: You do happen
to know that it was reading.
WOLFF DOBSON: So I'm just
gonna click Reading here.
Ah, that's correct.
So I can keep going.
TODD KERPELMAN: So now--
WOLFF DOBSON: Maybe it
was a coffee factory.
TODD KERPELMAN: So now, when
I sent you that first game,
you saw that little notification
right there on your screen.
Because I guess you were in
the middle of an "8 Bit Artist"
game.
What would happen if you were
reading your Gmail or something
and I sent you a
game invitation?
WOLFF DOBSON: If the
game is not running,
then what's going to happen is
you'll get a regular Android
notification with the
game logo at the top.
And it's going to say,
hey you've got a game .
If you click on
that notification,
it takes you to that inbox.
And you can choose to either
play the game or skip it
or whatever you want to do.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
this is pretty, pretty
standard notifications.
What if I don't have
the game installed?
WOLFF DOBSON: If you don't
have the game installed,
you'll still get
the notification.
But, when you try to
play it, it will take you
to the Play Store.
TODD KERPELMAN: I
guess that makes sense.
You kind of need the
game installed to play.
WOLFF DOBSON: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: So I could
really invite anybody,
whether they have
the game or not.
WOLFF DOBSON: Mhm.
TODD KERPELMAN: And hopefully
they will see the notification
and then-- I guess if I
were a game developer,
this might be a good way to
get word out about my game
because people have started
inviting their friends to play
and blah, blah, blah.
WOLFF DOBSON: If you
have a good game.
TODD KERPELMAN: I guess our
recommendation here would be,
unlike a real-time game--
go ahead and encourage
people to invite their friends.
Because you're not dependent
on that other person
to be on their phone, at
that moment, with the game
open ready to play.
These types of turn-based
games are generally
assumed that it might
take 24 hours or so
for the other person to
notice that it's they're turn
and to take their turn.
And, in this case,
it is much more
fun playing with
people you know.
WOLFF DOBSON: All right,
well let's keep going.
How do you set all this
cool turn-basedness up?
First, you've got to do all the
regular Google Play services
stuff.
It's covered in a lot
of our other videos.
Create an application, link
an Android application to it,
put that ID in your application.
We have lots and lots of sample
code and instructions for this.
And you should check it out.
TODD KERPELMAN:
Is "8 Bit Artist"
available as a sample game?
WOLFF DOBSON: It will be soon.
TODD KERPELMAN:
So what do people
have right now to look at?
WOLFF DOBSON: Right now,
they have Turn-Based
Multiplayer's "Skeleton," which
is just like "8 Bit Artist,"
but we've removed all the games.
So you're just passing a string
back and forth to each other.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
it's like a string
that I can modify, send it back.
WOLFF DOBSON: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: Perfect.
WOLFF DOBSON: One really
important difference, though,
is when you go to your
application in the console,
you need to flip this switch.
It's right there in
the game services
tab on the Play
Developer console.
If you don't, you'll
get weird errors.
So, how do you invite
people to a game?
This is our default
invitation screen.
You can write your own
invitation screens.
We have methods in the
game client for that.
But you're welcome to use ours.
And we actually
recommend it because it's
going to be familiar between
other applications that
use Turn-Based Multiplayer.
And it'll stay up-to-date if we
learn something and change it.
TODD KERPELMAN: So, really
only write your own game plan
if you're willing
to spend the time
to continually
update this thing.
And you're maybe a
large company that's
got a very strong brand that
you're concerned with keeping.
WOLFF DOBSON: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: If you're
a three person start-up,
maybe just use our UI.
It will save you lots
of time in the long run.
WOLFF DOBSON: Putting up
that screen we just showed
is really easy.
It takes this much code.
Just create an
intent and start it.
Then you'll need a
Listener on the other side
to check to see what result
you got and whether or not
they hit cancel.
That's what the Check If
Result Is Not Equal To OK.
So to gather invitees off the
list, just grab the data extras
and look for extra players.
And then you can add that
to your Turn-Based Match
Configuration.
TODD KERPELMAN:
I'm not quite sure.
Can you go back?
WOLFF DOBSON: Sure.
TODD KERPELMAN: This Get
String Array List Extra,
extra players.
What does this mean?
Is this grabbing from
the UI that I just
dismissed the players
I want to invite?
WOLFF DOBSON: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
WOLFF DOBSON: And then you
create a Turn-Based Match
Config using a builder.
Add that list of invitees.
And then call Create
Turn-Based Match.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's a
little bit more complicated
if you want to use Automatching,
which we absolutely
recommend you try.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
is still important.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: Some players
might not have friends.
WOLFF DOBSON: So, as you saw
when we were showing the demo,
there's Always Add
Autopic Player.
And anybody can choose that.
And then, in that
case, you'll get
a minimum and maximum
number of Automatch players.
This is a lot like our
real-time multiplayer code,
in terms of managing
Automatch players.
So you could look at that
as a reference as well.
But basically, grab
the min and max numbers
and create an Automatch
criteria object and pass
that to the builder for
the turn-based match.
TODD KERPELMAN: So,
I know in real-time,
we were encouraging developers
to also have a Quick Match
button that sets up Automatching
without going to that UI.
Is that what this code does?
WOLFF DOBSON: This code actually
will grab the information
from the invitation screen.
So when you pop up
the invitation screen,
you have an Automatch
button thing.
If you want to skip
that, and you just
want to have an Automatch
button, all you have to do
is follow the second
step there where it says,
If min Automatch players
is greater than zero.
Just say, Automatch Criteria,
Create Automatch Criteria,
Number of Automatch
Slots you want.
Which might be one, in the
case of "8 Bit Artist."
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: After that,
pass Set Automatch Criteria
for your Turn-Based
Match Config.
And then, call Create
Turn-Based Match.
Now, the way we're
doing Automatch, I think
is really neat.
We're doing what's called
Rolling Automatch, where
you can start a game,
take your first turn
and pass it on to somebody else.
So let's make that
concrete here.
Let's say I'm player one.
I've decided I want to play
against an Automatch player.
What happens is, I
take my first turn.
So, if I were playing
"8 Bit Artist,"
I draw my first
picture and I hit Send.
TODD KERPELMAN: By
this point, the system
doesn't know who
I'm playing against.
WOLFF DOBSON: It has no idea.
It just knows you're going
to play against an Automatch
player.
And at that point, it
goes up into the cloud
and waits around
to be Automatched.
Now, say Todd's playing.
Todd wants to play
and he hits, I
want to play against
an Automatch person.
At that point, the system
actually knows, well, OK.
There's this open
Automatch slot.
So let's just put
those guys together,
and have them play each other.
So when Todd gets
his game, I will
have already taken my turn.
And you'll be able to guess,
and then draw your own.
So Rolling Automatch gets
people going in the game
right away, even
in situations where
your game rules support that.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
the advantage here
is, basically, we don't have to
take that additional step of,
I'm looking for someone to play.
Oh, Wolff has decided he's
going to play with me.
OK, now I take my turn.
It basically gets me right
into the game a lot faster.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, I mean
if your game supports people
taking their turns before
they know who they're playing
against, you should totally
use Rolling Automatch.
It's very neat.
TODD KERPELMAN:
That sounds good.
WOLFF DOBSON: No matter
how your game starts,
you're going to get a
Turn-Based Match Initiated
callback from the games client.
You can register Listener.
As with all these
callbacks, you should
check that your status
codes are right.
Sometimes things go wrong,
like network errors.
Every callback comes with status
codes and you should use them.
We have sample codes showing
how to interpret them.
You may already
have a game going.
So when the game
gets started, you
should actually look to see if
your match data is not null.
If your match data
is null, it means A,
you just got a fresh game and
you should take the first turn.
And you should call whatever
your game initialization
steps are.
But you might have one of
these Rolling Automatch
games, at which
point, your like, oh.
We're already playing.
Never mind.
Just go straight to the
turn-taking interface.
TODD KERPELMAN: Cool.
WOLFF DOBSON: So that's what
this code is demonstrating.
So speaking of taking
turns, let's talk
about actually playing games.
For us, playing games
is taking turns.
When you're playing
a game, you'll
be passing around
this match data.
What's inside the match data?
First, you just get game
data, which is a byte array.
It's 128k.
It's whatever you want.
It's opaque to us.
We don't even know.
Whatever you store here gets
propagated to everybody,
on all their signed in devices.
So if I'm multiply
signed in, that's
going to get sent
out to everything.
You also get a list
of participants.
Each comes with a
unique participant ID.
For games that have not
finished Automatching,
you'll only get the
current participants.
And then you'll get a number
of unused Automatch slots.
Lastly, your gonna get some
status bits on the game itself.
There's Turn and
Match status bits.
Status bits like, is it my
turn, and is this game over?
Are we Automatching?
What's going on?
Even when it's not
your turn, you'll
still get these updates every
time somebody takes their turn.
So people can monitor their
game as it's going by.
TODD KERPELMAN: So we're
playing a four player game.
I'm player one.
I pass my state data, my game
state data to player two.
Player two takes a turn.
I will still get a
notification of--
WOLFF DOBSON: You won't
get a notification.
Your data will get updated.
And when you open and check,
you'll say, oh, yeah look.
Player two took his turn.
TODD KERPELMAN: So I can
see player two's turn.
I will see somewhere
in the Turn Status
that it's still not my turn.
Match status is that the
game is still going on.
WOLFF DOBSON: Exactly.
Speaking of participants, this
should feel pretty familiar,
if you've used
real-time multiplayer.
Participant comes with a
participant ID and a display
name.
And, if they
weren't Automatched,
then they come with a
Person data structure,
which has a way you can
get their profile picture
and things like that.
Actually playing
a game is create
some kind of shared
state, and then
call TakeTurn with somebody
else's participant ID.
So if I finished
drawing, I'm going
to say TakeTurn, and
put your participant ID,
not your Person ID.
If you want to pass it
off to Automatching,
you just pass Null In, and
it'll go off to the cloud,
assuming that you have
Automatch slots left.
And lastly, this
gets to Turn Order.
Turn Order is entirely
client dependent.
Each time you take
a turn, that client
decides who's going to go next.
Round Robin is a
logical choice, but it's
up to your game to decide.
And, as we were
talking about earlier,
sometimes, you're going to call
yourself as the next player.
And that's OK.
And what that'll do is
checkpoint the data.
And have that
uploaded to the cloud.
Here's a code, as we
were talking about,
for taking turns.
So when you click
the Done button,
find out who the next
participant is, increase--
I just have a turn
counter thing,
so I increase the turn counter.
Show a spinner
because it's going
to take some asynchronous
process to do this.
And then you call TakeTurn
with your match ID, the data
that you want to persist,
and whose turn it is next.
It's very easy.
After that, Null out your
turn data because it's
going to be invalid
at this point.
One last note on Turn Order.
Remember, Turn Order is in
the order of your client.
You can go Round Robin,
that's really common,
but a game like Bridge,
where the winner
is who's bidding start, we
give you that flexibility.
What happens when
the game is finished?
When a game is over, I made my
last move in a Risk-like game,
then I'm going to call
FinishTurnBaseMatch.
Once this happens, you can't
continue modifying the state.
Each player gets an
alert immediately
that says they can all look and
see what the final state was.
And then they call
Finish themselves.
And finally, after everybody
calls Finish themselves,
the game moves to
a complete state
where everyone
has called Finish.
Next, you can leave.
Leaving is akin to just
getting up and walking out.
That's saying I no longer
want to participate,
but the game can
continue going on.
So, if we're all
playing poker and I say,
ah, I gotta go pick up my kid.
Then get up and walk away.
That's leaving.
You can leave on your turn.
And there's actually
a separate call
for leaving not on your turn.
Once you give up your
seat, the game keeps going,
but no one can take your place.
So you can't just have a
continuously rolling game,
where thousands of
people have all joined.
The number of people who
join all the Automatch slots
are full, that's the last
person who can join the game.
But any number of
people can leave.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
this might be useful
if there was an
elimination type game.
And I get eliminated from
the map and I'm like, well,
I guess I don't want to
participate in this game
anymore because I'm out.
WOLFF DOBSON: Or the
client may automatically
call leave for you
because you're not
going to make any more
moves and we no longer
want to pass you the turn.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
WOLFF DOBSON: If
you cancel a game,
it just spontaneously
ceases to be.
We don't recommend calling
cancel, unless you're
doing debugging or
administration kills.
This is like a
marriage annulment.
The game never was.
It ceased to happen.
Lastly is expiration.
People do drop out of games.
It's very sad.
We have a built in expiration
that happens after two weeks.
If somebody just doesn't take
their turn for two weeks,
it just ends.
If Automatch does not find
a taker within 24 hours,
it also expires.
And if a game expires,
it can never come back.
It's over.
TODD KERPELMAN:
So take your turn
at least once every two weeks.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes, exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN:
You gotta figure,
if you're waiting that long,
it's probably not a very--
WOLFF DOBSON: So I
have a Q&A section,
where I've given you some
cues so you won't stump me.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh.
Here we go.
All right.
Say, Wolff, what happens if most
of my gameplay is server-side?
Actually, this is
a very common case.
We have seen a lot
of game developers
that already run most of
their logic on the server
because they want to
make sure it's fair.
And they don't always
trust the clients.
That sort of thing.
So can I still take
advantage of this stuff?
WOLFF DOBSON: Absolutely.
At this point, the
player matching
is going to be really
valuable to you.
And also, the
notification system
is going to be pretty
valuable to you
because it can be integrated
into the rest of their Play
Games experience.
We can also do Rolling
Automatch for you.
So, at that point, the turn that
you're passing back and forth
to each other is
probably just the idea
of the turn on your server.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
WOLFF DOBSON: And then
the game has to sync.
You have to do all of
you're own syncing basically
in the game state.
And they'll probably have to
be connected to the internet
when your game is being played.
TODD KERPELMAN: Makes sense.
WOLFF DOBSON: But
yes, absolutely.
Even if all of your stuff
is happening server-side,
you should look into this.
TODD KERPELMAN:
Clearly, server-side,
a little more of an investment.
If maybe I'm a small
company trying out
my game for the first time.
Maybe I want to do it
client-side at first.
Then it becomes very successful.
Lots of people are playing.
I then might shift to a
more server-side model,
if that's appropriate.
WOLFF DOBSON: Sure.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
Or really, you're just
an established game
that already some
server-side stuff.
WOLFF DOBSON: We have
lots of sample code.
You're welcome to ask questions
to us on Google+ or Stack
Overflow.
And drop us a line.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, we'd
love to hear from you.
Thanks, everybody.
WOLFF DOBSON: Bye.
TODD KERPELMAN: Bye.